eu acredito que nós estamos numa nova
era uma era digital onde a internet é
uma ferramenta capaz de trazer várias
liberdades pra gente e também uma área
de conhecimento em que o que é mais
valorizado em dia é o conhecimento e
novas habilidades
eu sou marcos lucas e eu quero mostrar
um pouquinho pela minha história o que
eu tô falando como é que tú inspirando
as outras pessoas fazem isso e eu também
têm rompido barreiras nesta era digital
e eu tenho ajudado as pessoas se o que
mostrar exatamente o que estou falando
então o primeiro vou pensar um pouco é
que a minha história eu nasci numa
pequena cidade do interior do rio grande
do sul que chama cruz alta alguém
conhece cruz alta
caramba me conhece né não têm cinema não
tem shopping tem nada lá e eu sempre
tive essa vontade de querer viajar
conhecer o mundo comidas diferentes
pessoas diferentes e prevenção realmente
diferente ou não nessas pessoas
mas mesmo tendo sessões parecia muito
longe porque não tem infraestrutura
adequada como cidades maiores né
mas até que um dia através de estudo e
conhecimento eu consegui uma bolsa para
estudar no japão que se chama a mãe
busca escola chip então governo japonês
dessa bolsa
sou extremamente honrado pelo governo
japonês por ter cedido essas verbas para
poder fazer o mestrado em
telecomunicações lá e não só essa
experiência foi muito interessante e
enriquecedora mas eu comecei depois e
vai em toque com um engenheiro de
software trabalha com software lá e que
aconteceu foi que eu comecei então nessa
educação tradicional vai pra escola o
colégio e faculdade uma especialização
talvez depois no mercado de trabalho
o que aconteceu foi que tem coisas que
nos preparam que nos falam antes né
vocês são estudantes têm variações nos
avisam e um aviso lá que foi que teve a
crise financeira global de 2008
e aquela crise que teve bancos nos
estados unidos que não faliram economia
toda foi movida eu vi colegas trabalho
sendo emitidas pessoa com a família
precisa
bom daqueles recursos para prover pros
filhos e por outras gerações
e quem passou por isso sabe que é uma
coisa extremamente angustiante ver
pessoas capacitadas por um fator externo
teve que ser demitido e depois ficou um
ambiente de trabalho muito gostoso e
decide demitir e eu queria simplesmente
ter mais liberdade
essa era uma idéia a espécie um colapso
não ser que o faria depois né
é uma liberdade maior então foi aí que
eu voltei para o brasil e comecei a
empreender para ter mais liberdade e
essa foto aqui é do meu quarto eu
comecei a fazer apenas detalhes no
quartinho para aquele lado de lá tem a
minha cama então acordava e ia trabalhar
e o que eu recebi em torno de três mil
reais que a gente paga impostos no japão
eles retornam para a gente então eu
tinha recursos financeiros limitados ea
idéia era que eu tenho que fazer é me
virar nos 30
mas eu sabia que o que você quer
financeiras vão acabar porque precisa de
mais tempo para fazer os projetos que
aconteceu foi que todo dia às seis da
manhã eu ia pescar e comecei a tocar no
congelador de peixe para ter comida caso
não tivesse mais dinheiro e depois que o
lancei esse projeto começou a dar certo
mas calma que eu não esperava
e eu comecei a refletir um pouco mais
sobre o que fazer da minha vida é o que
nos move o que pode ajudar outras
pessoas e foi que eu li essa frase deus
mesmo que ele falava que muitos gastam o
que não tem é compram coisas que não tem
dinheiro não tem pra comprar coisas não
precisam para impressionar as pessoas
que não gostam sempre pensar um pouco
nessa frase que vai completamente né na
reta contrária da mídia passa pra gente
de consumo e dessa cultura de
implantação quem comprar coisas pra
ficar mostrando que os outros também
visaram não é mas muita gente em fazer
né
em outra frase que chama bastante
atenção foi essa que o mundo é um livro
e eu vou lê-lo gente pensar no mundo
quantas pessoas mas 7 milhões pessoas
culturas fantásticas rituais fantásticos
sabe comidas excelentes
eu fico impressionado com isso ea outra
ali e eu vou eu vou desbravar esse mundo
conhece as pessoas é que são tão
diferentes assim talvez não seja
e eu comecei a refletir utilizar essas
coisas na minha vida até que chega um
momento que eu pensei que eu lhe amo
esse artigo no blog do longa nos mesmo
que falou assim eu consigo encaixar
minha vida e uma mochila colocar todos
os bens materiais em um pequeno espaço a
gente consegue então agora eu quero
mostrar a todos os meus bens materiais
são paulo por favor eu tenho duas
mochilas uma com as minhas roupas
materiais de higiene ea outra tem a
parte de trabalho mas eu virei então um
nome de digital a idéia é que o
empreendedor e que eu posso viajar a
qualquer momento que eu quiser pra
desbravar o mundo com as pessoas e
também fazer negócios fora e eu pratico
muito minimalismo porque não precisa
comprar coisas pra ficar mostrando os
outros né
quando a gente começa a pensar nesse
minimaliza que eles têm sabido que
excluídos de dívidas empréstimos quem
pode focar a for a criatividade
inovar não fazem isso e é também um dos
pontos da economia que é justamente
consumir menos para produzir mais que
consegue abundância e também amamos
financeira e o irônico é que nessa foto
vocês vêem essa mochila foi feita nove
anos atrás no sul das filipinas é a
mesma coisa até hoje funciona um rasgão
zinho e também uma coroa uma parte do
coração da mas talvez tenha que trocar
de 15 dias e outras vantagens também tem
é de um desinvestimento materiais
investir em viagens conhecimento a
línguas relacionamentos internacionais
comidas e aqui nessa foto eu vou
mostrando minha amiga como é que a gente
come grego na tailândia não gostou muito
mas é bem gostoso não é ruim não é hype
o time é alta proteína e aqui eu tenho
em cima do monte fuji no japão
e outra coisa é conseguir lançamentos
globais das pessoas como de toneladas no
mês
no espaço porque não têm amigos em
vários lugares né porque não poder ligar
para alguém de outro país e após cantar
o sofá e é isso que eu tenho agora é
bizarrices é muito gostoso saber quem
consegue sair fora daquelas cascas de
cebola encontrar um núcleo das pessoas a
tirar parte supérfluas encontrar um
núcleo delas eu acho muito bonito isso e
até que nestas andanças e conhece uma
moça o interessante foi a ren fazenda
ela queniano entrevistei a 1 na polônia
ea gente conversando bastante e ele
falou uma coisa interessante que ela
nasceu uma rima tribuno quem é pequena
foi o canadá com a família migrou para
lá e ela falando pra mim porque eles têm
um ritual uma tribo onde nasceu que a
tribo massai e nessa tribo é meio
bizarra assim vai acontecer mas jovem de
16 anos né crianças têm que sair da
tribo da zona de conforto e tem sobre
isso pensa agora no quênia
os animais têm lá em leões guepardos
hipopótamos ou sobrevive ou se morre é
um desafio extremo né zona de conforto e
o interessante quando eu toquei pra ver
a família dela ela encontrou um desses
jovens que tinha voltado e ela pensa em
caramba esse cara está desnutrido né
porque tem que ver o que têm comer
foi um decisão tem um leão também vai
comer é complicada situação e ela ficou
se eu contar pra mim que um carro estava
sendo 30 ele estava saudável e parecia
que ele tinha ido à academia todo dia
levantar peso
após encarar que ele parecia um homem ea
lei contra intuitivo isso na frente não
tem desafios não foi de desafios são
extremos assim a gente não tem desafios
que fazem sair da zona de conforto
aprender novas habilidades a colapso
financeiro como a gente lida com isso né
baseado nessa conversa que eu comecei a
pensar também da educação tradicional
que tem agora como é que a gente
consegue ter uma liberdade maior
coisas que não me falaram antes de
comprar a idéia da educação tradicional
nénão multidisciplinar é e se você não
gostar mais daquele ramo disciplina ou
se você gostar
duas disciplinas vai ficar oito anos
dando quem não tem uma forma de misturar
isso fazer uma coisa nova né
e se você não sente satisfeito com o
emprego que você faz você não tem um
propósito
muitas pessoas ficam no emprego por ano
sem propósito em brilho no olho e isso
vai matando elas e por isso que tem
várias pessoas depois que o emprego
ficou tanto tempo se dedicando a cni o
emprego e que acontece se não tenha
propósitos tem o propósito eo empregador
for à falência
as equipes vão ensinar pra gente uma
lida com isso
como é que ele vai ter a liberdade para
cuidar dos filhos que a gente tem nossas
gerações futuras
é muito interessante pensar nisso né é
isso que é legal que a iniciativa do fbc
em criar multidisciplinar entenderem
autoconhecimento para depois atuar em um
ramo mais de um ano e se ocorrer também
outro colapso financeiro global ou
nacional
como é que você vai lidar com os filhos
de vocês
a situação então analisando essa
história vem analisando todas as
perguntas que não falaram isso antes de
eu fazer essa esse trajeto
eu decidi criar uma fundação
internacional sem fins lucrativos para
cada ano e por um país subdesenvolvido
com um painel de cinco colaboradores que
estão confirmados são internacionais
empreendedores para ensinar às crianças
carentes sobre mentalidade sucesso
negócio passar um pouco dessa bagagem
para elas
obviamente a gente vai arcar com os
custos para isso e é uma das coisas que
não não tem muito hoje em dia e no país
agora na lista tão brasil a o quênia
índia tailândia e filipinas e outra
também nessa mudança fica pensando quem
quer conhecer pessoas interessantes
eu conheci essa moça que uma vez uma
nova mensagem fosse a marca eu quero
fazer um negócio digital também é eu vou
conversar então eu conheci essa moça ea
gente conversando ela falou assim a
marca quer fazer negócio digital falo 7
se alguém falasse a língua não eu falo
sete línguas têm formação em línguas
preciso são inglês e ela fez curso de
massoterapia balé é interessante porque
ela nasceu sem os olhos é um enxerga
gente conversando
fiquei fascinado com a forma que ao
trabalhar no computador e ela ensinou
muita coisa então baseado naquilo ela
falando que a sociedade não dá
oportunidades para deficientes visuais
ou também amputados outros tipos de
deficiência na isso é triste porque tem
pessoas brilhantes que podem agregar
valor nas empresas que a gente tem a
gente conversando é o meu falou assim ah
foi marcos
eu dou consultoria pelo skype é um
inglês e se eu tiver 100 clientes
o meu cliente como é que eu faço para
lidar com a demanda está falando sobre
escala habilidade de negócios
eu fiquei emocionado com isso porque o
que me veio à cabeça foi que muitas
pessoas nem do mesmo tendo olhos ela não
enxerga e eu fiz dela agora a a minha
principal colaboradora dos meus projetos
de traduções legendas nos meus projetos
digitais
isso que é legal que está muito feliz
com isso né porque é extremamente
talentosa e não só isso está criando um
produto total de treinamento em línguas
pra ela online
eu tô dando o máximo de apoio que eu
posso dar ea mensagem que quero passar
aqui é que tendo nós habilidades e
conhecimento utilizando essa ferramenta
fantástica internet ele pode fazer muito
mais coisas que a gente pensa que é
capaz
a gente pôde além disso ainda de
conforto também então ela deixou uma
mensagem para vocês que hoje eu
finalizar essa palestra com a mensagem
dela
eu quero tocar para vocês um pouco como
é minha vida meu trabalho minha rotina
como uma pessoa deficiente visual am
sobre a sua letra e cópia guardada no
ensino de língua estrangeira e moeda
inglesa
eu falo inglês italiano e espanhol
fluentemente e também fala a conversa um
pouco isso é com um latin já vai na
verdade não podia e alemão também né e
língua ele e ele vai ter
ae
todo mundo tem a sua habitação no tempo
que é melhor crescer então invista cada
um fez optar
acho que é bom mesmo só isso
nessa barragem está em liberdade
o objetivo é abrir